[Music]
all right we're black against nt3 a
dna okay so i guess
we can go knight f6
yeah let's play you know what let's play
let's play d5 i want to play d5
alright so this is what's called a kohli
system or blight plays e3 it's a very
peaceful quiet line
and um
black has many ways to respond to this
but i i think there's one line which a
lot of people don't really talk about
which is to just go whoops no it was an
l slip it should be seven is also
something people don't talk about
i was gonna go bishop g4 i mean i guess
we'll just do it now
bishop g4 thank you g cats it's not the
end of the worlds it just lost the tempo
and uh c4
okay let's go e6
basically play a queen's gambit
structure except with the bishop outside
the pawn chain yeah so the problem with
my loss of a tempo
is that it's kind of big that he got a
chance to develop the visual queen b3
okay so
[Music]
shall we go crazy 100 bits thank you
so what are the options here this pawn
is hanging the move you often want to
avoid ladies and gentlemen is b6
b6 creates a lot of weaknesses on that
side of the board all right particularly
look at that c6 square look at the light
squares that b6 weakens and white has
the very nasty move knight e5 that's the
problem if that knight gets to e5 we
start getting under significant pressure
so from a logical standpoint what move
makes sense therefore if i just said 95
is going to be a problem i'm going to
make a move which may look like a
blunder
and it's just to take the knight
it's just to take the knight now queen
takes b7 is often possible in such
positions i think here it's not as not
as good as it looks
after queen takes v7 start thinking
about what we're going to do
well knight d7 is the usual move
and we can play knight d7 but we can
actually grab that pod on g2 who saw
that that very same bishop and take the
pawn which is why he didn't go for it
now
we want to have some fun right we don't
want to just play
play like a
coward and what would it mean to have
some fun here i am proposing that we
sacrifice this fun
what am i noticing here i'm looking at
white's king and it's not going to be
safe on the king side it's very far away
from castle and queenside and here's the
funny thing if white takes this pawn on
b7 that actually does our bidding for us
because
if then white manages to castle queen
side i argue that the open b file is
going to give us very very nice play so
we basically pretend that there is no
threat we develop as we normally would
now in such positions we rarely put the
knight on c6 i think you guys know that
we want to be able to have this pawn
lever c5
so instead we develop our knight to d7
anyway
which is probably unsound objectively
but
i've had a lot of success with this kind
of idea
sacking b7
and it's going to take a while for for
white to figure out whether he's doing
this or not
all right
thank you jonah bro for the 100 bits and
thank you lou sasso
what should we take with i think both
pieces make a lot of sense we can take
with the pawn preserve the structure
taking with the knight is interesting
just to keep the center a little bit
more loose a little bit more open
i kind of like taking the knight playing
some very provocative chess here let's
stick with the knight trying to get him
to go e4 and weaken the center
so this is sort of a grunfeld style
approach where we don't
occupy the center with pawns we're going
to play c5 at some point thank you cj
hamster for the 14 months
are we gonna play g6 we might but i
don't think we need to i think we can
just get our bishop out to d6
e4 okay i think that's a mistake
where should we go
where should we go
what's the most active move here what's
the most energetic move
no not knight f4 that blown us tonight
careful careful careful
a lot of you guys are blundering a
knight
94 i think is definitely the most
energetic
now we're not threatening to capture the
bishop we do have a hidden threat here
which i'll spell out if he allows it but
i mean we want to play as aggressively
as possible because white's extremely
underdeveloped
and i feel like if we pounce on him
we'll be able to squeeze the most out of
the position
and what does it mean to pounce in such
a position well as i discussed
you know the ultimate goal here is to
open up the center that's the way that
you exploit a development advantage so
there and we have just the way to do
that as you guys know
and we could go e5 but
that gives the queen very nice pressure
on f7 i think it's better to go c5 whoa
in 20 bucks from howard up hambo
very much thank you so much
very very generous stuff going down here
thank you horned up hambo a3
and the knight drops back to c6
increasing the pressure on the d4 square
look at this stuff this is good stuff
for black
all right it's coming to d4
yeah knight d4 is coming and it's
unstoppable these knights are coming out
of the gates
this stuff is
very bad for white
i mean e4 e4 walked right into
right into what we were trying to go for
and then c5 and a3 i think is also a
mistake this knight wants to be on c6 it
wants to be on d4 let's get it to d4
yeah but d5 is not dangerous we go
knight t4 now the queen has to preserve
its control over c2 so he's got to kind
of go back
and then we can grab the pawn and weaken
his center even further
i think this is close to losing for
white believe it or not
because yeah queen h4 is a move to keep
in mind it doesn't do anything as of yet
okay so
does it make sense why we want to take
on d5 right i mean we
this just makes sense to weaken his
center as much as possible and open the
e file
later we can put a rook on e8
if i were white here i would very
seriously consider not recapturing but
he recaptures
this is a pretty instructive moment i
think a lot of people
have a hard time in such positions
because you start getting the temptation
to do something immediate but the best
approach in such a position is to
complete your development
nothing good is going to happen
uh when you have only one piece
developed this night is great but
without the support of the other pieces
without our king being safe it's going
to be hard to do what we want to do
so as dmn suggests we want to go bishop
d6 here this move requires patience
then we want to castle and only then are
we going to start thinking about more
concrete actions
another instructive whoa oh my god 69.
oh my god
this guy wants me to lose on time
69 subs what
ancient km king
are you freaking serious
oh my lance well i gotta get back to the
game we don't want to lose on time but
thank you for the 69
damn girl
damn girl
all right so what do we do here
uh do we need to do anything about this
knight or do we allow white to capture
it on d4
what do you guys think we should do
thank you so much engine cam
so a lot of you are saying yes we should
absolutely defend the night
what if i told you the answer is no
we do not need to defend that knight let
him take this punt
let's just castle
why is that the reason is because this
bishop is the only thing that stands in
the way of us dominating down the e file
making dr lono gifting to ancient m king
i contend that if white takes on d4
twice we will simply put a rook on e8
this knight on d7 can jump out to c5 and
perhaps even to b3 later
and so we are essentially replacing one
advantage with another one of the
hardest things to master in chess
is the idea of transforming your
advantage not often talked about
because visually you look at the night
and you say this is the best thing about
our position we want to preserve the
night or at the very least we don't want
to give it away
plus upon
uh
except
okay wtf
what
another 69 are you kidding me
oh my god this is epic
what is what is going on
oh my god
what is happening right now
oh my god this is unbelievable
i don't think two people have ever
gifted 69 subs in the history of my
channel
i am i am deeply touched right now this
is crazy
no this is insane maybe we are the same
person and i donated 138 it's possible
but that would be crazy so we got to get
back to the game again i was really
interrupted
um
many good moves in this position many
good moves in this position
uh what does white actually want here
what does white actually want
well okay let me approach this another
way i just think we should activate one
of our pieces i think we should activate
one of our pieces which one and where
should we put it
well bishop e5 would block the e5
wouldn't do that
rook c8 allows knight to come to e4
let's go knight c5 i proposed this move
the knight coming to b3 that is a big
threat and also we are taking the sting
out of a potential 94.
oh my god all right
all right
this is insane
okay so knight b3 is coming and
i mentioned this idea earlier
the knight is just much better on c5
even if we don't get to b3
everybody should understand that the
knight here is excellently placed
wow 28-25
now think about a good thing to think
about on our opponent's turn here is
where we want our pieces to be right
okay so we certainly do not want to play
knight v3 here in blender checkmate in
one
in fact we don't have too many ways to
defend against this made threat
but we have
f6 which is perfectly acceptable in such
a position because there are no other
ways for him to create any other threats
f6 is fine blunting the queen
and if anything it creates a stronghold
on e5 yeah bishop f8 was possible but
why overload why overload the bishop
thank you friendly fox queen d1
yeah now the king is basically busted
and
one thing to keep in mind in such
positions is that
um
when you are attacking
you should take free material if it lies
by the side of the road so one good
thing to do
is essentially take a pawn or take a
couple of pawns so that if the attack
doesn't work out
if the attack doesn't work out you're
still going to have something to fall
back on so the bishop is going to come
back to e5 which is a great square we
might as well grab that pawn while we're
at it right
and then bring the bishop back
i have to say white's doing a great job
defending here he's making it very hard
on me
but um now the material is equal so he
doesn't even have anything to show for
it
and we've got
very nice very nicely placed pieces
c1
all right so
to me it seems logical that the only
piece we have not activated yet and put
into the attack is the queen
think about where you want the queen to
be let's reverse engineer this rather
than just looking at random moves think
about where you want the queen to
participate in the attack
well to me queen b6 isn't as good
because of b4 i don't like queen b6 i
want the queen on the king's side where
everything is abandoned i want the queen
here or here
and so i like to move queen to d7 to get
it to h3 we could have also gone f5 pawn
to f5
paving away
paving open the pathway to h4 that would
have been i think equally as good jay
gruza thank you for the uh five months
all right
king f1 great move
x i prophet thank you now before we play
queen h3
i propose starting with bishop f4 and
i'm going to play this move a little bit
quickly right now
just because i want to save time but you
guys are going to understand the idea of
this move soon thank you funds for the
prime
it should be five all right
let's go to h3
let's go to h3
and if i've calculated this correctly we
are going to be winning here
thank you very much for doing this
speedrun oh thank you
i really appreciate it i actually missed
one detail here
you succeeded in bamboozling me now can
we just take on c1 perhaps
maybe we can just take the rokins i was
gonna take the bishop and try to mate
him
but now i think i think it's a better
idea just to restore the material
balance and uh
then just win a position or try to win
positionally
okay
i definitely could have played this
better than i did
for 100 for sure
but it's fine i also was a little
bamboozled thank you still tipton
okay let's snag another one
now we're upon up though
which is good no i mean of course black
is still winning i think pretty handily
okay one
little detail i want to point out before
we enter the time pressure stage
um
if white ever captures on f6 with a
queen trying to use the pin
what trick do we have there we can
actually set a trap that involves
quote-unquote blundering the f6 pawn
queen takes g2 yeah that's a common idea
taking that rook out with check so that
the queen will no longer be ps94
all right
94 is another excellent move man this
guy is just on
on the ball today
okay we gotta take it
okay what should we do now
oh my god there's a crazy line there
um
it's not so simple i think we can take
let me just take the pawn yeah rook c8
i'll show you guys after the game but
roxy ate there was an insane
there was an insane idea that white had
there which i think actually works
i'll again i'll show you after the game
why rook c8 i think was bad but
this is gonna be harry d6
okay so one
thing we could do is go like this take
and take e4
but then queen b3 is going to come and
win our bishop so
instead what we could do is we could
drop the screen back to e6
and after d7 blockade with rook t8 and
we can try to win that pawn
close this game is going to be close or
go bishop e7 which might even even
better just get that bishop out of the
danger zone
but i do
like the ideals of just blockading this
pawn
just blockade it just so there's nothing
could possibly happen with promotion
thank you will ferg for the sub
okay so bishop c4 we have to be very
careful about although it's currently
not possible a move like queen d3 would
be very dangerous for us here i have a
response to it planned but
that would probably be the best thing
that white can do here to try to test us
queen a4 same general concept if we move
our bishop he he pins our queen and wins
the game
so what should we do
what do you guys think we should play
here
so what we need to do is we need to
defend this bishop with our queen to
sidestep the pin number one and number
two defend the bishop we need to go
queen to d6 here
defending this bishop
or queen e7 but i like queen d6 because
now we have the idea of checkmating him
on d1 if the queen ever loses control
over this square
these kind of small points you always
have to factor in like where to put the
queen if there's two squares compare
them you know do you have access to any
other potential squares from one square
as opposed to another
okay
boom now king f8 might like you know it
might be interesting but i think king h8
is much safer
and queen f7 here is a very common type
of blunder like missing this mate is
easy
e5 whoa
that seems to be just panic
maybe just take the spawn
now we're up a million pawns here this
is winning for black objectively king g1
good move what should we do here
what should we do here
now remember queen f7 is a pretty
significant threat we don't want to
allow that move so the queen has done
its job on d6
we have to number one keep the bishop
protected number two
i would say we need to cover the f7
square queen f7 is a big threat you guys
are not responding to it
we have to go queen e7 right we have to
stop the queen from coming to f7 then we
might play a6 and accomplish our main
plan
yeah so now it's time for a6
and white can resign because the bishop
is actually trapped bishop a4 b5
and white will lose not only the bishop
but also the pawn
good game very well played by our
opponent who basically climbs back
from i would say a losing position
i was a little distracted to be in my
defense but nonetheless it was good
stuff quickly
let's just recap a couple of points here
um queen b3 bishop takes f3 yeah so here
after queen takes b7 we had this move
bishop takes g2
attacking the rook so that's why i think
he took
takes knight takes d5
now probably the best thing to do for
white is to take the pawn
and i would have gone rook b8
um
queen takes a7 and then c5 to make the
center go boom
this queen is in big trouble here i like
i love these types of positions for
black
even if they're on sound
so cd knight d5 e4 big mistake weakening
the center knight before attack the
center reroute the knight put it on d4
trade on d5 open the e file
develop your pieces
and
i think that here castles takes take
somewhere here i made a mistake
i think rookie 8 was fine but after
knight c3 i actually think this move was
not good i think this move was not good
because
i think it commits too early
and yeah according to the computer the
best move would have been rook c8 which
i saw actually no the best move would
have been
bishop to e5 or rook c8 bishop b5 is
probably the best
after queen d2
what's the point of bishop e5 it's not
actually to improve the bishop
the point of bishop e5 is actually to
create
a possible
anchor point for the queen where it
pressures up to
so this is the big game changer because
now white's king can't really hide out
on the king's side
i didn't want it because it blocked the
e-file what was my mistake my mistake
was that i didn't think flexibly enough
i thought the e file is the end-all
be-all but in reality you have to give
up a little bit to get a lot and here
you have to give up temporary control
over the e-file that you still are
controlling it to get the queen of h4
well if white castle's queen side you
have the pin which is an important
detail as well
it all seems very easy with the engine
thank you mating threat five months
the knight c5 rook g1 good move
it's a good move because if he had gone
rook d1 to stop the fork i would have
gone queen g5
and beat him to the punch i mean
obviously now it's impossible
rook g1 is a very nice insertion this
this stops my queen from accessing this
diagonal right queen d1
bishop takes h2 and now it's just not
quite as clear even though of course
black is much much better queen d7
yeah bishop f4 maybe
was also not
ideal takes bishop c1 i'm checking with
an engine though this is all correct
here
there there there no black is i mean we
were always much better
i think all the way until the end now
why didn't i go uh rook c8 that's really
the important
question
the reason i didn't go roxy it is
because of d6 and there's a beautiful
line here
rook c1
queen takes c1 bishop c1 d7 and white is
winning amazingly
the pawn is unstoppable look at this
bishop guarding d3 and defending the
pawn at the same time so
that i calculated and decided against
going for this
so
for that reason
i decided to take on a3
number one winning upon number two
trying to get the bishop back to d6 to
blockade the pawn
well plunga boone the point of knight c5
is that it it doesn't stop knight e4 i
explained it misleadingly it prevents 94
because of knight b3 not because the
knight actually controls the square
if that makes sense queen h1 check then
just root q1
okay
queen h1 doesn't do anything
rook g1 queen h3 king e2 and the king
actually evades the checks
in h5 king e1
black can take the bishop but not stop
promotion
yeah so you got to be careful until the
end pass pawns that's one of the themes
of today all right guys i think that's
enough um this has been an epic stream
i'll give any last
chances for if anybody else wants to
give 69 subs i'll take it
but um very sneaky stuff here yeah this
was a nice game nice way to end i think
all right guys i open a raid i'll i'll
throw him throw him the peeps thanks
again everybody much appreciated thanks
for hanging out hope you had a good time
see you guys later bye
[Music]
you